People might say, I, I'm,
I'm a little alarmist when I mentioned a
potential civil war, but let me clarify,
like I don't, I'm not saying
cause I brought this up before,
I'm not saying it's going to be like, you
know, 18 hundreds, two big battlefields.
But at the same time,
what people don't seem to realize when
it comes to history is that when you read
about World War II,
we've condensed all the highlights into
a very short paragraph or a series of
paragraphs. And you don't realize
the war was several years.
There were periods where nothing happened,
right?
I was in Egypt during
the second revolution.
You could look down and you could see
ty for your square people screaming,
laser pointers, helicopters, Apaches. And
they announced in the news, we've just,
we've deposed the
president two blocks away.
A dude's eating a
cheeseburger at Mcdonald's,
watching a football match
as if nothing's happening.
So when you look at these street battles,
the political violence,
when you look at the, the, the biased
Banning's, you look at the dude, um,
there was a guy who fired a couple of
rounds at a police officer in Eugene,
Oregon.
Then some bombs got planted at the police
department or somebody planted bombs
at a statue in Houston.
It starts to feel like there's some kind
of political violence that is bubbling
up that can't be mended at this point
when a lot of this comes from the
suppression that we're talking about
where people don't feel like they have a
voice or that voice is being suppressed
by an opposing ideologies, you know?
Yes. But it is really
complicated and it's, it's,
I can't claim to know
how everything happens,
but what I will say is I believe social
media is responsible for the political
violence. I believe it's, uh, it's
not just about suppression. It's you,
you look at, um, the systems
that were built Facebook, right?
What content can make it to the
front page of your Facebook posts,
of your Facebook profile. When you're
looking at your newsfeed while Twitter,
Facebook has to build an algorithm
to determine what matters.
Most companies then figure out how to
manipulate the algorithm to get that
content in front of you.
Because you know,
at most you can see what three posts on
Facebook. So what happens is early on,
companies quickly found out that anger
drives the most shares of any emotion.
All of a sudden we see a wave of
police brutality videos. Yeah.
There was one website that posted almost
exclusively police brutality content
and it was like Alexa,
400 in the world,
some ridiculously high number
of blew my mind. I knew p uh,
someone claims to that they're making
six figures writing police brutality
articles because it was
pure rage bait, right? Yeah.
Content that just shares really easily.
But that content constantly being put in
front of somebody breeds and ideology.
You then tell someone,
did you know that you know,
white supremacy is on the rise and there
are 11 million white supremacists in
the U S and they go, I can believe it.
But that's nonsense. It's just not,
it's just not the case.
You know,
the Anti Defamation League in the SPLC
say that at rough estimates or maybe like
10 or 12,000,
but people really believe that there is,
like at the president is secretly a Nazi
and that he's being propped up by the
secret cabal,
or there's an alternative influence
network on Youtube where you and me or
somehow trying to convince people to,
you know, this is ridiculous. Well,
that's the, the, the AME thing.
Yeah. What was it called?
A data and society. And that's,
that's that nonsense. Yeah,
we did.
We get connected to,
or we outright adjacent or we
bootleggers that one part of the,
it's a network that feeds into
extremist ideologies and other,
they connected me with people. It's so
schizophrenia, the way it's drawn out,
that little map where one person's
connected to another person.
What I said to her, I said, Barbara
Walters interviewed Fidel Castro.
Did that make our communist, you know,
that's what I tweeted at her. I'm like,
you're crazy.
This is a crazy way to look at things.
But what happened with that story?
Media reported uncritically.
I reached out to a bunch of journalists.
I know, I know a ton of journalists.
I'm a, I'm a member of the online
news association. You're like, I've,
I've been a speaker at their events and
I'm reaching out to these journalists
like, hey, why did you guys write
that? That's just completely fake.
It's got my name like my name in the
middle. Right? You know me, right?
You can call me to quote you.
They don't do it right.
They just uncritically report it.
And there's a couple of reasons for it.
The media, uh, Facebook recently
changed their algorithm. I don't know,
this was a while ago. They may
have changed again. But, uh,
it was a huge hit to the incomes
of a lot of these companies.
When all of a sudden news articles
stopped appearing as much because Facebook
wanted friends and family to be more
connected and less so news organizations.
So these news organizations who write
this viral clickbait and rage content
weren't getting as much traffic. So what
are they? You know, they have to go crazy.
They have to, you know, and so it's,
it's a downward spiral of where these
journalists all follow each other.
They start producing. I don't,
I don't think it's a conspiracy.
They produced this stuff.
I think they're hired specifically because
the content they produce is viral and
it's viral for a reason. Right.
And so the more they produce it,
the more they eat their own, you know,
excrement essentially. And then boom,
it's a game of telephone where they're
sitting in a circle constantly telling
each other the craziest things.
And it gets crazier and crazier.
But another aspect of it is when they
read an article saying, you know,
Trump is racist, it goes viral the next
day. They can't read the same article.
So they, right. Trump is the most
racist the next day they have to,
they have to keep one
upping it and it gets,
we talked about this with Forbes articles,
the term nasty surprise,
they use it with tech.
Like they'll say the new galaxy
s 10 has a nasty surprise.
The new iPhone 10 has a nasty surprise
and it keeps saying it's hilarious.
It's almost like there's a form letter
and they just take whatever Xbox stick it
in their nasty surprise and it's,
it's 100% and click bait and it's Forbes
and you telling me that Forbes that was
essentially is, it's like user
contributions. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And I,
I could probably submit an article,
they have like a network of people,
I don't know how you get approved,
but there's a lot of articles that just
get written about like the new video
game today. So it's like
a clickbait title. Yeah.
We'll just get some ads
has a nasty surprise,
but it's almost like they have like
a pattern that they've just accepted.
This is going to work,
but it's not a conspiracy.
It's just likeminded people who
are only ever around each other,
sharing the same things among each other,
believing all at the same things.
And so you'll notice that certain words
emerge specifically among certain groups.
You know, like the left, we'll use certain
words and then if like learn to code.
It doesn't appear that
much in left wing rhetoric,
but the conservatives and the anti
identitarian types understand what it is.
And so justification for banning someone
for saying learn to code regardless of
the context seems insane.
Yeah, that seems insane.
It seems like you got one in
particular is almost independent.
I mean not almost that's indefensible.
Absolutely.
Like there have been people who, uh,
let, let me, let me, let me be fair.
There are people on the left who
have been banned. Absolutely Hobson.
There was a lot of Venezuelan accounts
that were banned and a lot of people were
very critical.
I saw Abby Martin was,
was criticizing this because they accused
them of being government actors cause
they were pro Venezuelan government.
But the most, the one thing,
there's some occupy Wall Street
activists who absolutely detested me.
They lie about me,
I do not like them for doing this.
They were banned abruptly
for literally no reason.
And this is what's more worrisome
to me is that no one defended them.
No one defended them because
conservative certainly won't,
but neither will the mainstream,
you know, ideological left.
These are activists for class issues,
for international issues there on the
left squarely and they were accused I
guess of being bots or something just,
it was just an abrupt purge of like
50 accounts and some of them were like
independent citizen journalists just wiped
up and with no recourse, no recourse,
none whatsoever.
So I mean at some point you have to
realize how important Twitter is when the
president does on it.
Could you imagine if there was a physical
space where everyone was talking and
the president shows up and everyone
keeps yelling at them and they're all
talking because you had that lawsuit
where they said it was a public forum.
Imagine that happens and then a private
private individual bars you from hearing
what the president has to say. Right.
It's a complicated issue. I very,
you know,
you get a lot of people on the left
saying private businesses can do whatever
they want.
That blew my mind because the left
was usually about not letting massive
multinational billion dollar corporations
get away with suppressing speech.
But well that was another thing that
people get pissed at me about Jack Dorsey
and rightly so that he said that
it's a human right that deal,
the indicate online as a human,
but the fact that he said it,
but yet all these people are banned.
So how [inaudible] like to take
away someone's human, right? It,
there should be an egregious example.
I mean it should be something like,
I mean doxing, someone like calling for
violence, like trying and buddy buddy.
But even then, but the, clearly that's not
the case if Kathy Griffin still online,
but hold on, you can kill a human
being and get 25 years. Right.
Good point. So you can literally
strip someone of their, of their yes,
everything and still
be perched permanently.
This was one of the things that Jack
and I discussed post podcast. I said,
you know, when we were going back and
forth about doing this again, you know,
and told him,
uh,
I would really like to see if there's
some sort of a path to redemption.
Like, uh, you know, for example,
for Milo, I mean, who's to say,
like we talked about yesterday about
Christian ecoline who was a white
supremacist,
who realized the error of his ways and
then became this activist against racism
and now he gives these Ted
and he's accepted by everyone
as being this guy who's
achieved redemption and really understands
the error of his ways with Milo's
banned for life. Milo is only
like 34 years old. Right?
How old is Milo around there?
I don't know.
I hope I didn't make them older
than he is. It probably be mad,
but whatever it is, like who's
to say that Milo, you know,
in three years from now won't have
a change of heart or you know,
have a fucking acid trip or something
that makes sense. I'm a different person,
but if you're banned for life,
we are.
We throwing people away like you ever
see that tweet from? I'm going to say,
I think it was Tyler, the creator where
he said, how is cyber bullying real? Just,
you know, like close your
eyes side. Go outside. Close
your eyes. That's, you know,
I'm sorry man. You want a band
hate speech. I can understand.
I'm no fan of hate speech. I think it's
wrong. I think you shouldn't, you know,
target people for specific
characteristics. We should
respect one another.
At the same time,
I'm also a human adult who
understands sometimes people are mean.
You ever walked out, you
ever go to a, you know,
a subway in Los Angeles and some guy
starts calling you all the names in the
book. What are you gonna do about
it? Nothing. That's just life.
People are mean sometimes have they
punch you, they crossed the line.
But on Twitter, you know, Milo wants say
mean things. Block mute. You know what?
I'd do that precipice. Yeah. Mute Utopian
of black people. I blocked some people.
Yeah.